partir d'afrique et de planteurs qui
auraient des intérêts en afrique à un
trafic de chlordécone organisée après
depuis un pays d'afrique par des
planteurs martiniquais le pesticide à
l'époque était interdite ils étaient
revendus dans un magasin de bricolage de
fort de france
c'est l'une des déclarations d'eric
godard la semaine dernière l'ancien
directeur de la rs était interrogé par
les députés
il répondait aux membres de la
commission d' enquête sur le chlordécone
présidée par serge letchimy
il explique également que des chercheurs
avaient trouvé la molécule du
chlordécone en 1991 et que les hauts
fonctionnaires en charge la santé avait
répondu à l'époque qu'il ne fallait
chercher dans l'eau des rivières que ce
qui était demandé
c'est à dire par exemple des matières
fécales et rené cela confirmer
qu'effectivement il avait découvert
notre leur déconne il l'avait signalé
mais qu'il n'en avait pas de trace pas
darchy parce que ça avait été fait de
manière informelle retour en martinique
nous sommes à sainte-marie chez un
planteur à la retraite reconverti dans
le bio la banane est désormais derrière
lui nous avoue-t-il
et il se souvient d'un jour où il était
dans une réunion à la préfecture avec
des planteurs il aurait assisté à une
scène qui l'a marqué eric godard presque
sommé de se taire par les autorités
alors qu'il parlait du chlordécone
quand monsieur godard a développé sur le
chlordécone la dangerosité du
chlordécone
j'ai senti que tout le monde était
contre lui et il a valu qu on le
complète speedy en guyane y compris les
gens de la préfecture y compris les
liens de la préfecture il y avait des
gens là oui j'en ai fall qui était là
aussi qu'ils n'étaient pas contents
parce qu'il avait il y avait développé
son sujet concerne concernant le clos
l'école 14 octobre 2005 claude lise
c'est qu'il boit l'eau du robinet
dépolluer à l'époque il est président du
conseil général et visitent la toute
nouvelle usine d'eau potable du lorrain
qui vient de s'équiper en filtres anti
chlordécone que voilà mais ce n'est pas
l'état qui impose l'installation de ces
filtres
c'est une demande expresse de la sopam
art à l'époque il ya de gros doutes sur
la qualité de l'eau le conseil général
décide de protéger la santé des
martiniquais
tout le monde savait qu'on le savait
l'état aussi des mails à président lise
un ton médecin et connaissant des
situations en particulier des
populations a proposé que ça se fasse à
un prix d'ailleurs exorbitant mais si tu
n'as absolument nécessaire de le faire
les élus de la région qui à l'époque
était aux affaires sont surpris de ces
déclarations et ne comprennent pas que
certains fonctionnaires ne rien faire
condamner ces gens qui ont fait preuve
de passivité
à mon avis ces os ensemble ou est du
déjà porté plainte
être attentif s'ils ont fait preuve de
laxisme là il faudrait qu'il paye
pendant dix ans plus de cent mille
personnes de la côte atlantique ont bu
une eau du robinet contaminée aux
pesticides
la commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale reprendra ses travaux à la mi
octobre